The advantage to this technique is that many people can rate their own
personalities relatively quickly. Also, because the answers are limited to
usually around five categories. Such as strongly disagree, disagree, neither
agree nor disagree, agree, and strongly agree. They can be scored and summed
easily. They're objectively scored, not subjectively, like projective tests
are. Now the problem, as always, is the questions and the answers must be
reliable and valid. If people answer questions one way at one point in time
,but differently, say, a month later, then we don't have a reliable
questionnaire. In addition, sometimes people may give biased answers. And
finally, if a person doesn't really read the question or, take them seriously
and just puts random answers in, they're not valid reflections of a person's
personality. So good personality questionnaires take years of research to
establish the reliability and validity. And have ways of detecting random or
inconsistent answers.